You may have come across a situation
where someone has sent you some data,
but for whatever reason,
it's been split into multiple files.
This is often done,
because there are too many records.
And they exceed the maximum number
of records any one file can handle.
For instance, the maximum
number of records you can put
into an Excel worksheet
is just over a million.
So, if you had 3 million records
of data, and you wanted to
use Excel to hold the data, it would
need to be split into three worksheets.
But then how do you use all of
that data in your analytics?
That's where unioning comes in.
Unioning allows you to take multiple
datasets and deal with them as one.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's easier to format or
clean up one large dataset than to have
to repeat these same operations
across multiple datasets.
And then bring them together afterwards.
Unioning appends multiple data
streams into one unified stream.
This makes a longer dataset containing
records from both of the original
datasets.
Picture stacking records from one file
on top of records from another file,
making sure to line up the columns or
fields that are common between them.